lisa is with us in Raleigh North
Carolina hi Lisa how are you good Thank
You Jay for taking my call
sure what's up okay so my husband and I
are trying to pay off our debt he's
currently the only one working because
I'm stay-at-home mom and graduate
student and so we've got pretty much
everything paid off except for our two
cars and then my student loans my
student loans are pretty large and
there's a good portion of them because
they're graduate loans are unsubsidized
so the interest is about $300 a month
that just keeps accruing so we're trying
to figure out where to best put our
money should we be paying off our cars
and then kind of roll that into the
student loans or should we kind of
divide that and pay the $300 a month in
the accruing interest just to keep it
from from accruing how much do you like
the car we have one of them is 27,000
and the other one is 24 good lord
and how much is your loan debt I'm
embarrassed to say it's about 90,000
okay and you're at home yeah and he
makes what but he just well here for a
couple years he was in and out of
construction with just kind of the crash
of building things and stuff that didn't
housing market wasn't that great he's
actually just started his own business
this past year so we're still trying to
figure out what he's making but on
average he's been able to bring home
probably about 5500 a month
5500 a month yes which sounds
suspiciously like 66 thousand a year
okay around that yep no and you're
studying what I'm in counseling I'm in
my last year's on starting my clinical
internship actually in May okay and you
will finish that when May of 2017 it'll
be a one-year okay
and then what will you be making
that I'm not sure I will so I still have
a very small child at home and two older
ones that just started school so I'll
kind of be still trying to be at home
and then kind of working part time but I
don't have any idea really we're
spending a lot of money right now as
broke as you all are to get a degree
you're not planning on using no I will
use it I just we kind of got a surprise
with our last little one so that's
definitely slowing things down as far as
me getting out into the workforce
full-time so that's yeah I will
eventually be working full-time and
dealin how are you paying for the
balance of this education um how we
paying eventually or now anything that
the finisher from here forward how are
you going to pay for the finishing of
your counseling degree with the
remaining student loans and with my
internship it's only I mean at this
point I've done so it's literally just
the internship it's not it's not adding
any more money really to the loans it's
just now that I'm done and I've done all
my schooling
now the loans are going to come and
start have to be paid yeah yeah okay um
well you've got an untenable situation
the math you're giving me is scaring me
to death
thank you and these cars are both just
insanity
I don't know that was he making two
hundred thousand a year before or
something but yeah before it wasn't that
much but before was better but the
vehicle that he does have is for his new
job he can't afford it
he's in construction he doesn't need a
$25,000 truck he just needs a truck you
guys have cars you absolutely cannot
afford you're going to go bankrupt I
mean you're you're you are rapidly
running this into the ditch you have a
a low-income and you have a hundred and
forty thousand dollars in debt and fifty
of that is on cars there's just no way
Lisa this has to change and it's not me
telling you I mean the math is just
screaming off the page here and it's not
Dave Ramsey but me being mean to Lisa
that's not the point
you guys have gotten yourself into a
corner and you've got to sell these cars
they've got to go away quickly for you
to make this a crime because your
student loans are coming due mm-hmm I
mean how much is your house payment
um 1,100 yeah and your car payments are
that much between the tears about three
350 and 430 okay so they're 800 okay and
yeah four combined yeah not what I'm
talking about yeah I'm talking about so
yeah and then you're going to student
loan that's going to be that much and
more yeah and you know and there's a
baby right there that wants to be fed so
these cars don't fit this equation at
all all right it's going to put him out
of business and it's going to force you
into the workplace before you're ready
to go back and so they the only shot
you've got to turn this thing around is
get yourself a couple beaters and get
these things gone for the math to work
you just I don't any margin take fifty
five hundred minus these figures you're
giving me you see what I'm doing and and
it's just there's not there's I'm not
any food left I mean it's just that
that's why you're calling me because you
were you hadn't done the detail the math
and I've done so many budgets I can do
them in my sleep but you haven't done
the detail math but you were feeling it
in them you know in them in the mist
it was sneaking up on you the dark mist
was coming yeah I do for sure yeah so I
think you guys can make it but you're
going to make some radical decisions
here you've tried to do several things
at once that you could not afford to do
so something's got to go and I'm trying
to keep you at home in this discussion
his incomes got to go up and these cars
got to go away for that to happen
okay I didn't for you to be able to
finish this internship out and that and
you know are they is it a paid
internship yes it is but it's it will be
at least you're not paying yeah okay
yeah yeah no at least yeah at least I
don't have to pay but it'll be it won't
be that much okay all right cool
well yeah I mean if that's what I would
do if I woke up in your shoes is to turn
this around that way and you guys just
got to sit down and do some really tough
math together and you know what is the
best way though as far as if we did get
rid of the cars to attack the student
loan debt should we refinance that to
lower the interest rate from six point
eight to something lower no we're not
going to get any lower than that on
those but that's about what the market
is and so it's not an interest rate
problem it's a cash problem it's an int
it's it's what we call shovel to hole
ratio your shovel is your income the
hole your ends the amount of debt and
your shovel to hole ratio right ii is
horrible
it's doable when you get rid of the
$50,000 where the cars start it starts
to turn around then because I've got
another eight hundred bucks a month to
work with here so hold on we'll walk
with you through this I want you to to
go into the class Financial Peace
University it's a nine week class I'm
going to pay for it because I've been
right where you are scared and didn't
know what to do and I'll show you what
to do and I'm going to be in Raleigh
April 27th so give her two tickets to
that event as well Kelly this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here hope you're enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my bear
own YouTube channel yes that's right
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel I'll tell them myself that I'm
kidding I'm panic so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you